as far as fight news goes it's it's the
it's a slow time right now um kind of
slow so this is what in the biz we call
the off seon for UFC fight fans this
would be the offseason you got a banger
happen at the end of December we will
have a fight campaign for that we get
some great guests lined up but uh as far
as you know just we we've been on a
bender here where you've had great
content great fights one after the other
UFC really cranks out and then like the
entertainment business they shut it down
you have some fight nights those Apex
centers basically ent's backyard the
crowd's not really there those are a bit
of a bummer they don't really count
where I come from but uh they still
count on these professional fighters
records so they're knocking out few of
these fight nights until they get to
December 16th they're just edging you to
December 16th and Then star in January
then January then we're in full blown
season